bueno nuestro rol ha sido principalmente
llevar cuidados de salud a las
poblaciones más vulnerables entonces
estamos enfocado en muchas poblaciones
que están alejadas de los servicios de
salud o que viven en zonas más remotas y
ahí llevar la atención a cubrir también
hicimos mucho trabajo de prevención en
muchos países trabajando también con
poblaciones de públicos prioritarios
como mayores en muchos países y claro
también intentando mantener los
servicios de salud y los sistemas de
salud funcionando en muchas partes del
mundo porque sabemos que también con la
pandemia
y causó una situación de mucha presión
sobre los sistemas de salud y ahí
buscamos también mantener las
actividades más allá de la respuesta a
kobe también funcionando de la mejor
manera posible pero han sido muchos
desafíos hemos estado en más de 70
países con respuesta a kobe y seguimos
ahora también buscando ofrecer
tratamiento a la gente que está en la
internación y tenemos como desafío
principalmente el acceso a las
herramientas médicas como las vacunas y
los tratamientos que ahora están
aprobados bueno ustedes tienen también
una misión muy particular como ha
afectado esta situación la atención que
le prestan a otras crisis u otros
conflictos que atienden alrededor del
mundo generalmente
si es justamente lo que vemos hoy con la
situación de la vacunación es muy
preocupante porque vemos que hay muchos
países donde ya hay pocos profesionales
de salud ni siquiera estos profesionales
están vacunados y eso crea una crisis un
problema claro para
un público prioritario que debería ya
estar vacunado y la razón por no estar
es justamente en la inequidad en la
distribución de vacunas la inequidad en
el compartimiento del conocimiento para
que produzcamos más vacunas y en muchas
partes este profesionales no están
protegidos y muchos están enfermos y
muchos se están muriendo en realidad
porque no están inmunizados y con eso se
crea ahí también un desafío mayor para
responder a todas las cuestiones de
salud que existan porque hay muchos
países que ya estaban un poco
profesionales y ahora están con menos
resultados de esta inequidad en la
distribución de vacunas de comida bueno
el señor felipe carvalho coordinador
regional de la campaña de acceso de
médicos sin fronteras muchas gracias